to take a commanding lead in the sink
field cup
back to you jen and jazz yeah he
definitely has a chance
well without question
i thought there were two results either
a draw or a favorable outcome for
victory for hikaru and really the move
queen e4 does look
bad that's a very
uncharacteristic slip by magnus
queen e4 and again we'll just take that
because what happened a moment ago
why that was so significant we'll go
back here for this moment
carl who just played the move rook a8
obviously attacking this pawn on a4
everybody like queen f4 and
this move queen f4 had in fact
multi-purposes obviously attacking two
pawns
but after the move rook d6 notice that
the move
the rook is now stuck if you will
on the square d6 and simultaneously the
pawn on
a4 has been protected which gives white
the opportunity he needs
to be able to activate his rook and get
some
play down the b foil or to have played
king g2 with the idea perhaps
of rover rook
up and over getting his rook from f1
into the game
in fact what he did was with this move
queen e4
queen f6 now the queen is beautifully
defending everything on the king side
there's
no danger whatsoever to black's king
and this rook is threatening to come to
d4
snap off this a pawn and really
only white uh white's advantage has
grown considerably i'll totally agree
with maurice a hundred percent on that
one
yeah definitely development indeed
so a couple of slip-ups in mag for
magnus in this line
and it is today's game you know we
talked a little bit about uh
taking on b5 as well but uh
earlier yeah exactly which kind of led
to the potential for nakamura to seize
the initiative
right now after queen to f6 so magnus
has played queen to b4
queen to b4 okay
magnus really drifting here a bit i just
don't so supposing he's trying to uh
to respond to rook d4 with a queen b7
i understand that yeah i do
understand that queen b4 let me just
kind of get the zen of that for a moment
and as we do that uh what do you think
about this move queen before
maurice well queen b4 is probably
not so bad a move considering the
circumstances uh it turns out
that that's the computer's first choice
believe it or not yes
but also komski has just played the move
queen before
so there's a simultaneous queen before
sighting
in the other game as well but after
queen before inkomski's game
aronian has now played the move f5
and we've got action heating up in that
game
f5 attacking the e pawn and it looks
like this e pawn
is under so much threat so many pieces
queen knight rook and pawn
that this trade is necessary and i don't
know if there's any real action here
after queen check
king over knight takes on f5
and maybe just a forced trade here i'm
not sure what's happening in this
position
it does seem as though this bishop will
get the opportunity to go to this square
at some point
and pressure the pawn aronian seems
fearless at the moment thinking you
haven't been doing anything i feel good
f5 on the board so we're going to be
looking at this game
as it heats up towards the end of the
first time control shining yes
great wow f5 i love it you know we were
looking at queen before
and you didn't you didn't think it
smelled right no but the idea you were
trying you know they were
white was being able to defend but now
ronnie entries also have the same
instinct
and as we as we said uh both of you guys
are big fans of larsen
right well i came up with this uh kind
of a kasparovian move
whenever i think of f5 and weird
position i think of kasparov because
you know we seem to find these like
dynamic and strange looking modes
and the move f5 really starts to be far
more attractive when
white played this move king
f2 i'm very surprised by that move by
god akamsky because then again your your
eyes are automatically drawn to the e3
square you should be thinking
i've got a rook i've got a queen on the
e file can i play queen to e3
i thought that godda was going to
play the very solid choice king g2 he
didn't go for that
and that might be a crucial difference
in in the positions we're about to
see in the game oh yes those little
moves matter we do have uh we do have a
couple more moves in after that so after
d8 queen b4 um f5
e takes f5 g takes f5 on the board on
the board
because this was a crucial moment right
here right now
i was thinking about the move rook c5
for white the idea here is obviously i'm
attacking your queen and i want to
close the position down i was thinking
that in case
i forced you to retreat there is that
peace sacrifice we looked at
maybe it works in that circumstance
something like e5 with the idea of
shutting
or closing off the king's side that was
not god's choice
instead you say we have e takes f5
g takes f5 has been played on the board
that's right
wow you take that
because i i like that line that maurice
was showing
wasn't it something with queen e3 check
king g2 as we like to say in the trade
box then followed by knight takes d5
and the bishop's coming to d5 and all
the uh forces seem to be working in
concert but
right after for example a trade
uh white's king at the moment sure that
queen on e3 monster queen
would scare the bejesus out of me uh
with this
idea of bishop d5 uh
obviously unable to shut that queen out
because of the
the power on the on the devil yes you
mean that
rook on e1 would be a mistake because of
the
rook d2 invasion exactly and and very
important to be able to just control
that square like a
such a powerful queen is so huge but
let's see after g takes f5
after um g takes f5 does iranians still
have a big initiative
that's the question so i guess he's
thinking now rookie one
similarly could run into some 94
problems
all right should we just uh take a look
at that for sure
rookie one so now 94 chat
threatening to blast open on this
night that looks good for very good
because it would seem that white would
have to take on e4 now and then after
rook takes d4 where uh
yeah i mean you can take on b7 but that
king on f2 looks woeful indeed
yikes forward also to check on e3 it's
ugly to say the least
i would have i would want nothing
whatsoever to do with that line of play
and here um
the thing that i would like to do
suddenly if i was white was
is to play a move like queen c5 trading
queens but all that's going to do
is encourage you to play bishop to d5
anyway here i think defense might be the
order of the day
right you need to coming back with a
queen
on d2 to maybe harass
uh black's king a little with the move
queen g5
hunkering down does seem like a wise
decision in this position
right and now ian and we gotta ask
ourselves how can we increase our
position now and then you always have to
watch out for c5 here
but you've got your little queen g5
check business
uh but okay let's just continue that
because c5
does make a great deal of sense i'm
going to give you
a check anyway now you can't trade
queens because you've just put your pawn
on c5
so we assume for a moment you move your
king
i could drop back with my knight and i
like the defensive forces
around white's king this looks all right
i could also have given you a check
check yeah exactly you can keep checking
me
this is probably so this is a this queen
does seem like the correct the correct
way to go about things here
well assume that black puts his bishop
on a very
healthy square bishop d5 if you give a
check
in this case because i haven't played
c65
i could now invite a queen trade
and this looks just fine for
black i don't see any particular
problems here
maybe still some i don't know who's
whose king is uh more vulnerable
um no this should be fine
i think queen d2 however is a necessary
defensive precaution
by gada yeah it looks forced
and he has played it not surprisingly so
queen d2
key defensive move and now we're not
sure if uh ironing can make much
from his f5 but uh uh grandmaster ashley
uh
thoughts on uh um taking back on f5 and
queen e2
well knight takes f5 seemed natural
after the queen e3 check idea
but aronian decided to keep the tension
in position by capturing
on f5 and queen d2 believe it or not
might be a real inaccuracy in this
position because
aronian can simply guard against that
move
with queen dropping back to f6
no queen g5 check anymore and this pin
might start to become significant
on this knight here black is apparently
a little bit better in this position
according to the engines it's giving a
variation look at this incredible line
queen to f4 knight e4 check
and after pawn takes rook takes on d4
definitely a crazy looking line
especially since it's giving
moves like queen takes f5 just dropping
back
queen to g7 and now black
has got the king somewhat exposed the f
file is interesting
bishops might move totally totally
mad line that could happen on the board
and so computer-esque
you can't imagine white seeing it maybe
black won't see it either
we'll have to see how that goes but i'd
like to point out what's happening
on the in the other game because carlson
is down to 3 minutes and 46 seconds
and counting 346 now he's going to get
seven minutes because of 30 seconds
added each move so
another 14 minutes he'll have per move
i mean 14 minutes he'll have total but
still
sitting on three minutes with nakamura
at 19 minutes
that's got to be crazy he's got to be a
lot of stress nakamura just played the
move rook to a7
so clearly carlson in trouble and
needing to move he's just played king g2
we'll see how this one proceeds in the
next few moves
but the number one player under pressure
from the u.s
number one player who's looking to score
his very first victory
against his nemesis back to you jen and
yaz
thank you maurice yeah so it looks like
uh
carlson nakamura um plenty of juice left
in this position worked at a7
um with the idea of stopping queen b7
and perhaps
soon renewing the rook the d4 threat now
it's too certain soon to play with d4
because queen b
8 check is in the area that's why i
think nakamura is likely to follow suit
with carlson's king g2 and move his king
to g7
and uh create that rook 34 idea
right so just to be clear what what
you're mentioning jen
is the immediate desirable rook d4 to go
after when the a4 pawn unfortunately
loses
to the double attack check and
black loses a rope sunglasses would be
smashed sunglasses would
so you have to preface that aggressive
rook d4
move with the move king g2 now here i'm
not
i i don't know maybe this move rook a7
is brilliant
it looks a little bit funny yeah it does
it's like having your work on a7 not
defended by any pieces
exactly so i'm just i'm just not saying
it's bad
it's just i agree it looks awkward it
does look awkward
you just want to push that pawn forward
so now if rookie 4 you can just play
something like queen c5
right precisely that is the in exactly
the idea that rook d4 doesn't
uh work after queen c5
picks up a nice little tempo over there
uh
against the rook on a7 how are you
feeling about queen trade ideas now
for instance queen well yeah that's why
i was going to do queen d6
okay so you have to keep the pawn
covered that
now that your king's on g7 i think
you're giving me a chance to play
uh moves like queen c3 check and rook a1
although now i'll play queen b4 oh queen
g4 jack
yeah and rook a1 your queen's not on f6
anymore
so you've given me this
uh opportunity to maybe defend the pawn
so we'll go back just a moment here jen
and
after a5 how about this move
just cold-bloodedly going after the pawn
in this way
with you so long as your queen's on f6 i
like that very much
because you're stopping rook a1 uh in
this
line of play
we are giving white the opportunity to
shift
and play for the d file
a number of moves have been played in
the game and
again uh bringing up maurice's point um
not much time for magnus carlsen so he
really has
to quicken the pace yeah that definitely
will make the defensive task more
difficult
for uh magnus anytime you're
on defensive in both the clock and the
position so after work to a7 king g2
um it looks like a rook d8 your move was
played and uh queen g4
check king f8 so sorry pardon me he
after king g2 what was
the choice of magnus rook a8
you mean yeah nakamura part nakamura is
the one who's better in this position i
know it's hard
yeah yeah gotcha hard to realize i
hadn't got you on that one
okay then came queen g for check
that's right and then there's king f8
okay
okay uh things are
very very uh
scary here for a second what if i were
to play
the obvious queen d7
in the world immortal words of nikolai
minev
gift me the pawn on c7
right so you're trying well you can't
i'm not going to take on a4 and let you
take on c7
no that would be a dreadful trade uh
strategically
and what's your idea if i play queen d6
my idea behind
i i'm not afraid of your trading queens
and i was actually in fact going to play
rook
to encourage you to trade queens just to
so
our uh viewers
now the bishop attacks the rook and of
course we're threatening to promote the
pawn to a queen
all right we're getting some fast and
furious moves here and this would
obviously be
uh quite sufficient for white exactly so
um instead
in the game we had queen g4 check king
f8
um queen b7 oh magnus did play so queen
and now instead of uh the lemon uh
looking
queen d6 uh e6 was played
okay with the move e6 by the way is this
a sweet queen trap or what
i mean uh even with sunglasses on we
should all see
that rook d8 that would be nice dirty
dirty dirty
idea of hikaru evil so rook d1 is
basically
forced to stop uh to control the square
d8
that's right i like that little queen
chap though oh that's the kind of thing
that could work if you're not playing
the world number one
yeah yeah yeah yeah well it's almost
like you have to snicker to yourself
when you play move like e6
nakamura please you know one minute
games you know he started from one
minute and now he's here
right oh we could all very easily fall
for such a queen trap
so i'm assuming rook d1 it has been
played
magnus has even though he's in time
trouble
he's finding all of these moves
and still looks
like what maurice said when they got
into this ending originally
that great fortress potential for white
yeah making it hard so any kind of queen
trade offering that black makes white
has a really nice response right
right first of all we could ignore it
because if queen takes
um well maybe in this situation where
you wouldn't want to but
no but the other thing is that um that
uh white can also take and play rookie
seven jack in these lines
precisely doing that activity is key
because now it's gonna be hard for you
to take on a4
because we'll capture on c7 always
uh and once the rook gets to d7 which is
just a dream come true from white's
perspective
white's got this nasty bishop h5 just to
make uh
blacks uh right counterfeit
right and instead uh nakamura has played
queen to e5
so okay let's try to understand what
that move
was going well clearly it's over
protecting that pawn on ec7
so that we can try to release our rook
and take on a4
precisely so so rook d1 uh stopping that
queen track
rook d8 had to be dealt with
queen e5 uh
protecting the pawn on c7 so that we can
play rook takes a4
now magnus to play
a little under three minutes on the
clock so ten moves to go
right um the pressure's on
queen's still on the board it's not easy
for him to come up with these moves that
quickly
as soon as the queens are traded off
it's a little bit easier so here
i would shift direction i would say look
congratulations you you've protected
your pawn on c7
let me nibble over on over here
let's go back to your other idea sorry
what was the other
idea oh no no no no i like rocketron
well i don't know if i like it but i'm
just saying
instead of taking on a4 immediately we
could also we could also consider
um i guess if we play queen g5 though
you can just transpose
well queen g5 uh
you release uh the defense
i'm going for the cheapo
oh a women's chest i mean okay
uh tough stuff look at this rook h5
and then queen f6 and now i'm set up
for the defense of my a pawn
that would be very nice queen d2 i
with the doubt v8
with the double threat though i want to
take the pawn on h6 and i want to defend
boost my a pawn that the a5 square
all right so let's let's retreat all
right and try to find a
better move after work to h1 okay we we
have this position on the board magnus
to play
not much time we're expecting him to
come up with rook h1
down to just a minute here no way wow
no way i mean you think these moves
come naturally you've got to keep a
little bit of initiative otherwise uh
you know the exchange for for nakamura
well foreign well exactly he's got to
he's got to keep uh black busy
with the a4 pawn he can't just lose that
a4 pawn
for nothing and he's got to keep the
pressure on
hikaru as well so so yeah
we're keeping our eyes on this game
because you know so thrilling to see
the world number one in time pressure
and it does look like he played rook h1
and we've got something with maurice
maurice
indeed i just want to point out the
clock situation
30 seconds and counting 30
28 counting down now he's got to play
quickly let's update
the board position this is what we have
on the board now
and he has played rook h1 so this is
coming soon
but the we have a clock ticking down to
14 seconds
seemingly cannot be correct because he
did play rook to h1 pretty quickly uh
and no way the time goes down to zero
here
i'm seeing this clock go down and so
there must be an issue with this
time we have here because it's saying
double zeros he did play rook h1 in time
so we'll see if we can get that correct
because right now
the internet feed is giving us as no
time on the clock so let's see if we can
get the updated time there
his rook h1 did appear on the board so
he's still
clearly okay in the position but
man the time situation is so crucial it
could just be
over any minute now one mistake in time
pressure and he could blow it so
nakamura
completely in the driver's seat update
everyone uh we do have the official time
um the update is 52 seconds so under a
minute
uh that and and look at magnus he's
looking nervous
um it does look like uh he looks like he
put his work back to d1 so
maybe hikaru did renew the threat of
rook v8 perhaps perhaps he just moved
his queen back to f6
queen back to fc is that what happened
i see that the rook came back to d1 okay
i'm expecting
ah king g7 oh okay let's
update it because i think instead we've
got uh instead i'm hearing the
king g7 happen and then work b1
rook h1 was played and then king to g7
so going for counter play in a different
way wow hitting on that b7 square
now and now uh nakamura playing queen to
e5
queen's on e5 already no no now nakamura
on move
exactly after rook v1 right so rook b7
is uh magnus it's still about 50 52
seconds 51 now
you know when when um maurice was doing
the countdown
12 seconds 10 seconds 0-0 it happens
it's extraordinarily
rare but it has happened sometimes you
press the clock
and you don't hit the button fully you
just kind of do it
you know like with a hand slap and not
realizing that you
you you haven't properly pushed your
button
you know that would have been
extraordinary that would properly push
your body
you got to properly um so
i mean this is uh this is really
unbelievable that uh
nakamura is putting so much pressure on
his his real villain
yeah so far yes and very exciting for us
fans
and we've got something up he's taken
off the board work takes a4
and here we're gonna go rook b7 i mean
magnus has got to play it quickly
and if anybody knows how to put pressure
on opponent who's on time pressure it is
nakamura
yeah so he's not gonna lay magnus have
um an easy time of getting out of this
in time pressure
in fact i wouldn't be surprised if we
see a number of pretty quick moves from
nakamura not that that's a recommended
strategy for those of you at home
no but if he hasn't seen it if he's
looked at if he's calculated
yes if it's no surprise he will try to
play quickly absolutely
okay but now here's the point rook b7
played
a very obvious intention
of capturing this pawn on c7 by the rook
which would lead to an attack against
the f7
pawn if hikaru drops back with a rook
this just doesn't look very
edifying the rooks
on a8 and a7 don't make a very good
impression
so i suspect if ikaru is playing for the
win
he's going to do it the other way with
his rook and maybe play rook on a8
a7 right and we are up exchange but
pretty hard
to figure out how to make progress here
now what do you think about taking a cue
from uh
his countryman and playing h5h4 in this
position
because i just don't see what what we
can really like chomp on in this
position is black
exactly and again turning you know this
turnip
into a rose uh that h6 pawn has been a
kind of a handicap
for hikaru and your suggestion of h5
h4 to try to expose uh white's king
makes a lot of sense to me as well
yes and looks like we have got another
move in the board we'll we'll update
that whenever possible um
after work to b7 uh magnus carlton had
one minute and 14 seconds so those
uh 30 second increments do add up and uh
give him uh a little bit of her up yes
maurice has some thoughts to share
maurice please
well that carlson game is obviously
extremely exciting i just want to
also get your attention on the other
game as well
it looked like aronian had some time
pressure problems himself he was down to
four minutes
to move so the game proceeded with the
move queen g7 is the last move we saw
queen to c3
and queen h6 threatening maybe possibly
this move queen
h2 check but not seriously so queen d2
was played
by komsky and aronia decided to repeat
moves with queen to g7
and queen to c3 is komski's repetition
so they might be worried about the clock
situation at least aronian might be
worried about the clock situation
and is willing to repeat moves and maybe
go towards a draw
because mu 40 is already three moves
away so it's hard to get that
tantalizing move 40 where you can then
sit and relax
and really figure out what's happening
in the position so we'll see
what happens in the next couple of moves
will aronian repeat with queen to eight
six
or will he try to come up with something
else in an effort to
win the game and get back into the
winter circle at least get in the
winner's circle
to somehow be able to challenge nakamura
and carlson
who are in the thick of it right now
back to you guys yeah we're getting some
some excitement in both games here at
round three of the sing field cup now
let's go back to carlson nakamura where
we've got a little bit of a time
squirmish
and a rook to a7 so he did move the work
on the
fourth rank back to a7 right you weren't
quite expecting that and now we have a
little creeping move as they call those
tiny little uh queen moves um to e7
well in this position it's like one of
those things where white has maximized
everything his king is good his bishop
is good his pawns are good the queen the
rook
and so but you got to make a move and in
time trouble
you got to make any move and this is
actually a pretty good move it's
basically a waiting move
it also stops it takes out some of the
bite away from that h5h4 idea as well
precisely so it's like are you nipping
in the bud before it could even
even happen because we're going to play
h5 i mean we might even just have the
frontal attack queen h4
and it would be a little awkward to try
to defend that pawn
because uh potential rook h8 leaves the
other rook on a7 hanging
exactly now this is a very very awkward
uh setup that black has with his rooks
i mean i know hikaru did this
in order to win that pawn on a4 but
black is
really has no intentions whatsoever of
ever capturing this pawn at trading
rooks on b7 because this pawn on b7
would just be too strong i mean it's
almost a move that you just like tune
out
absolutely it's like it works like a
genius move because most players would
not even consider it
precisely so i think that maurice is
right his intuition earlier said that
white's white has really good fortress
uh uh style position and we're seeing it
right now i don't see
nakamura leaning back it doesn't matter
if he's wearing sunglasses he's leaning
back okay for a second he looked like he
was a little bit agitated but then
nodding uh vigorously hard to figure out
this guy um and what he's feeling at the
board
and now we got a something something
capture a trade of rooks so maybe
maybe the moment yeah let's try to
update this so where takes b7 was played
and i just said that this would be a
brilliant move because
most uh strong players wouldn't consider
it but nakamura not any strong player
what on earth is his idea here all i can
imagine
is that after a move like rook b8 his
intention
is to try to utilize his
c pawn and to uh
but i think you're going to get in a
position where what we would call
in chess mutual zugzwan that is to say
neither player
being able to make uh headway
getting into this kind of thing so let's
see if we're getting an update here
so rook takes b7 c takes b seven has
been working
all playing on the board again uh just
uh
interesting to see how the top players
in the world the world elite real
look at the exceptions right this is a
very big exception too
allowing that pawn to b7 and we
are expecting on the board as expected
yeah the little the little thread of uh
well actually i guess the thread is
something like bishop c6 followed by
queen c8
because um queen c8 immediately you can
release the pawn on on c7 but
for instance if it was white's movie or
bishop c6 might be very strong and then
it blacks the one who's in drama yeah
well
okay so uh
always yeah and i'm giving myself a lot
of moves
right well this might be one tricky
trappy idea that hikaru has in mind
is after the move what about this move
queen
d6 jen if you go queen c8 which is the
desirable
idea right you'd like your queen on c8
queen c8 your queen gets trapped
after the move queen d8 right and now
we're compelled to
trade which is not what white wants
white
i d unless there's some you got to
calculate
who's fast well actually i beg your
pardon i can't even
cross the d file because the rook would
be on the d file in that case
let me go back so i think after
queen d6 white's going to have to step
back with this queen
maybe some move like queen a4 to try to
harass
black's king over here maybe with a
queen g4 check
i still have to feel that this pawn on
b7 is so exceptionally strong
white should be fine and
let's go back to maurice who has some
thoughts i think on the other game
indeed erodia did not repeat moves in
that game and looks like
he wants to win he wanted to maybe
repeat moves just once
in order to get a little time on the
clock but instead of repeating with
the move queen to 8-6 he made his
intentions clear
by playing the move bishop to d5 and
after
knight back to e2 looking to trade
queens aronian didn't mind that he'd
plunk down the bishop on the b3 square
attacking the rook
adding a little bit of pressure this
game seems very close indeed
38 moves in two moves to make aronian
with three and a half minutes on his
clock make that four and a half minutes
because he gets to make
two moves and catch up in time so trying
to win in his game is aronian
clearly wanting the point instead of
just a half a point in order to get back
in the contest
back to you guys wow so two
great games uh approaching time control
um
nakamura and carlson just a few moves to
go before they get that extra 30 minutes
at the end of 40 moves and after queen
to d7
nakamura did play c5 he did play c5
okay and that erroneous game the one
that i have got up on my screen at the
moment
that still looks pretty even to me
uh but i gotta admire the fighting
spirit of aronian who's behind on the
clock
made the repetition and said no i do
want to play for the win
let's go back yeah all fighting players
here at the same field cop
and one of the nice things about having
a tournament like this where
um the organizers invite all the
opponent all the
all the players because you know the
players like nakamura get more
invitations than other players
of a similar rating because of the
fighting spirit absolutely
well surprising to me i think i would
have plunked down the move queen c8 at
once
uh had i been um in
carlson's shoes in this game instead he
played queen c6 and i
can't make heads or tails of that move
as to what the difference was i would
like to keep that
rook prisoned imprisoned
by my queen on c8 but in any case
how could hikaru possibly
squeeze anything from this position
on the king side of the piers i think
jen the only thing i can see
is at some point you toss that h pawn up
the board allah ben
larson and you hope you can expose
white's king to some
types of frontal attacks with the rook
and queen
um yeah that's right i mean it does look
like
like uh naka has played a kingside move
so
um either you move the king or he did go
for the h5 idea and it's nice that we
got this kind of
dark square fortress so he almost
doesn't even have to look queen and the
rooker defending
um all the key points in the position
and uh just see if he can uh
he may be something out there and it
looks like he played king f6 he may have
prefaced
he did play king okay so king f6 on the
board
and again the only thing that i can see
that could
cause white any discomfort is
uh an eventual pushing of the h-bond
just three moves ago for time control so
um that's what happens with this
30-second increment that
even a time time deficit that looks
dangerous uh
often evaporates um and now magnus was
59
seconds but with just two more moves to
make
but objectively speaking how couldn't
could hikaru make any progress if i put
my queen on c8
and i keep it there what on earth
could um hikaru possibly do
to upset this set up by white
so you're not really worried about h5
and h4 you'll just you can just i'll
take it when i get there
i'll take it with the idea of not
allowing a rook to g8 check that was why
i wanted
queen c8 in the first place and if i
have to play a move by the way
it would probably be king h3 and back to
g2
so again i'm just thinking to myself i
just don't see
how hikaru is
able to make any progress and after king
episodes we do have a
a move similar to what you studied after
kingdom h do so
um instead of playing uh his king on h3
he just
does just uh just killing time killing
time killing time until we reach that
40th move the promised land right
exactly um and we've got some uh
some more thoughts from grandmaster
maurice ashley i think in our
our other game approaching time control
approaching actually now has turned into
reached
completely the time control has been
reached by both players 40 moves
and a simultaneous sighting again you
saw king f6 in the nakamura game
and now king f6 by aronian and this
position looks very equal
they've both gotten to move 40 they're
going to take a good look at the
position and see whether or not they
want to keep on playing
but it looks like there's not much to
hope for in this position
and in the other game yes i got to agree
with you
how in the world is nakamura supposed to
win this position
this b-pawn is protected forever and how
do you make any progress
well nakamura may start thinking about
advancing his f and e
pawns in order to somehow get this
bishop from protecting this pawn but
man that's going to expose the king
quite a bit and i don't see how
that works well there's going to be tons
of perpetual check
opportunities maybe he's thinking of
trading queens too so queen d6 and then
maybe later f5
and and see what happens very difficult
though
looks more or less equal to me but
nakamura really would love to win this
game
there's the reality is he's only playing
for two results as you mentioned
no way he loses the position so why not
torture
carlson for as long as possible to make
him know
i'm not afraid of you dude watch when i
have white next time
back to you in the studio just a few
days and nakamura is going to get the
white pieces against magnus carlson
right the big question on everything
everyone's mind is sunglasses or now
besides the other questions like e4 d4
or c4
i fear that if it works we're going to
see him again
i fear if it works and good point
maurice
that when you are on the sunny side of
the torture
do do uh your very best to grind your
opponent
certainly hikaru has been ground down
numerous times by
magnus so he knows what it feels like to
be on the receiving end
of the torture but this is a good point
you've made a very very good point
and thank you for that maurice
excuse me after king e7
and let's just say let's go back with
our king for a moment
and queen d6 and in case of queen c8 now
i'm beginning to have some doubts
maurice was mentioning that at least
black does have this idea of f5 let's
just play a few
lousy moves for white for a moment so i
can show you
what i mean this was what maurice was
saying is
if you can play e6 e5 to e4
and block out that bishop from
protecting that pawn on b7
you may you may have a shot at winning
i still see the bishop coming to c6 in
this case
though after bishop c6 you do release
the c pawn so okay and we've got to move
king g2 f5
has been played wow okay hikaru
so instead of trying to play h5 he went
for the only other way to nibble on the
position
exactly so we do have in the position
the queen
still on the e5 square he has played
king e7 and after king g2
f5 in the words of walter brown
immediately
immediately you get in f5 and just one
move now
for magnus to make the time control
after he makes this move he will receive
his extra 30 seconds
30 30 seconds and 30 minutes
more importantly 30 minutes you get that
bonus of 30 minutes and it's such a
relief
after being under so much pressure um to
get that extra 30 minutes you just feel
like
somebody threw your lifeline okay so
this is going
we're going to have two very long hard
fights today
which is excellent love it oh yeah right
before the rest day right so
um tomorrow of course there's not gonna
be around we're having a rest day and
the day after that
um we'll be back in session with um the
second half of the sinfield cup
yes well if the second half is as
exciting as the first half we're going
to be really blessed here
with the most elite tournament on
american soil in 50
plus years uh that uh
the tournament is going to be exciting i
think to the very very last round
quadrupole by the way now that you
mention it
since this is round three the two the
two games that we're seeing today will
be
uh featured in round six so it may come
down
that uh hikaru nakamura
and the reason for that is they wanted
to avoid um three blacks
in a row of course exactly so there's a
triple color threat
and because of that naka and magnus will
actually be playing their their
last game in the penultimate round in
round five so also very exciting though
i mean that'll be on a saturday so
perfect day to watch a battle like that
oh for sure
and my suspicion is that that game will
be the
decisive one for the first place who
gets the 70 000 and who gets the
50 000. indeed indeed it looks like it's
headed in that direction
wow um with the the fine form that both
of these players are in
and magnus has reached the time control
after the move f5 he has played in
in fact the move queen c8
and he's leaving it up to hikaru to try
to figure out
can he squeeze this position
any further hey how's this for
an idea guys i've just come up with a i
think
a genius idea how about queen to d6
queen d6 has been played with the idea
that if white does nothing okay just
bear with me so at least i can show you
what i have in mind
king f6 and not to play the moves e5 and
e4
but to say to you look your queen
the white queen is trapped
on the c8 square i'm going to play
king e5 and just to show the idea
i'm going to play king d4 and if you go
i'll play king here and notice your
queen isn't moving
and eventually i'm going to play c4
move my king probably to b3 and i'll
just run my
cpan up the board how's that fabulous
idea that will definitely
go in the magazines and books if that's
the way that nakamura wins this game
that's why yes unfortunately i think
white will be
obligated to play e3 at a certain moment
let me go back and show
where the moment we reach this position
probably white has to stop black's king
from crossing to d4 with the move e3 now
the fact is that does weaken the
bishop's
support if that's going to be a decisive
factor or not i'm not sure
nice idea though cute yeah
very uh very reminiscent of uh
nigel shorts a great victory over jan
timmerman we had a similar
uh quinoa one and that was a really a
middle game so that was totally
astonishing this an end game
it would be just a a really cool way as
uh magnus said earlier in the tournament
the economy of forces he was talking
about his brilliant f3
defense against gotakamsky whenever you
see a king
you know march into the into the battle
and and win the game
it feels you you used it you used
everything in your position
in this case i mean aesthetically not
only is it very pleasing but to do it
with the queens on the board
is most especially so and actually it
looks like uh
magnus has uh preempted that immediately
and has played ether
didn't even uh we didn't even have to
play king of 65 that game was getting
nowhere near him
right didn't even have to provoke the
move what do you say jen
uh aft since we've made the time control
how about uh
taking a break for and coming back in
five minutes or so
what do you think sounds like an idea
yes we're gonna have some really
exciting long games here so uh don't
uh don't go away we're gonna be back for
more from the sink field cup in just a
few minutes
hello and welcome back to the sink field
cup
we are here in st louis the strongest
tournament in american history and
we are looking for ways for nakamura
to uh squeeze a knife in here against
carlson i mean it looks like
he's got he's got a good position right
he's got the exchange he's got this
potential c
pawn push but right now magnus is
holding on to everything
yasser you were trying to to invade
on the break i came up with a rather
imaginative
idea for magnus we've just seen the move
king h2
for hikaru pardon me to defeat magnus
and the idea is we're expecting that
white is going to shuttle his king back
and forth and say
as we say in missouri show me okay
i show me state
i'm thinking of the move king g5
so let me just show you what i have in
mind
to first of all i want to trade this
pawn on g3
for this pawn on h4 after the swap
trade i've exposed white's king
and i can try
another break this time with the f-pawn
before notice we were trying to
um bring our king across
the center of the board
oh my goodness i believe a drop
five was played and a draw then
a girl was a dream now i wonder if after
h5 um
nakamura anticipated that white would
just stop your little plan and play king
h3 himself
possibly so you know the king is not so
exposed if uh h4 king takes h4
correct oh my goodness well first of all
let's go back
let's go that must be the reason so a
pretty thrilling contest in which uh
we thought nakamura might even take down
carlson
um but instead i draw
this was a great felt that we did think
was more likely but we just didn't think
it was going to happen so soon
no and i really did expect hikaru
as we've seen so many times in this
career especially in the u.s
championships that he was playing
he would press in every type of position
and i just don't see
why he agreed so
quickly probably probably because he saw
more and just uh respects magnus maybe
over respects but he just thought he
probably looked at the idea h5 didn't
think he could get h4n because of king
h3
and thought that i'm not i was wondering
about the other idea what he thought
e5 e4 was going to amount to wow also so
those seem to be the two possibilities
right because right now we're just
we're basically just at a standstill so
black needs to do
i don't want to use the uh meta the
often bad metaphor
used by journalists stalemate right that
has such a specific definition in jazz
correct
but here it's like we got to we got to
break through in some way your king
march is not working
h5 uh doesn't seem forcible h4 rather
and so it's got to be e5 but
what do you think what was going to do
against that i don't know and i'm really
intrigued when maurice
does get an opportunity to speak with
hikaru and madness which i'm sure that
will be forthcoming shortly
we'll definitely quiz them because i was
stunned by the draw for frankly
i think that this is a position you
still
need to torture your opponent
absolutely i think you see that it's a
draw
okay i think the illness was on
white in this final position to make the
draw
get a chance to talk to both of the
players so that's exciting um
speaking of which if anybody has any
questions uh don't forget to use our
hashtag
think cop s-i-n-q-cop um
if you get them in early enough you
never know we might even be able to
oppose them to
our players right here exactly
all right that leaves us by the way at
the halfway point that does mean of
course that
hikaru keeps his lead a fine result
and we have another result in we can see
that uh gatakansky and lavon oronion
either a very long and elaborate draw
offer or
the game is also over and the draw has
been agreed
okay so the first uh day of
the sinkhole cup that has drawn no blood
but
certainly still plenty of excitement and
good chest
as we mic up uh our our tournament
leader
um nakamura uh we should point out that
he still leads the tournament all draws
means the tournaments
are exactly as they were last round so
nakamura in the driver's seat with uh
carlson carlton is just going to be half
a point behind
and uh to remind everyone tomorrow we've
got a free day
so everybody can rest up and maybe study
your tactics and then
on the 13th that's a thursday
we're going to see gotta kamsky excuse
me on the 13th is friday
the 13th friday we've got godokonski
playing white against magnus clarosand
and levonaronian white against hikaru
nakamura
excellent and the reason nakamura gets
two blocks in a row is because he had uh
two whites in a row
to start the event that's exactly right
we can't give them that much of an edge
yeah even though he's
halo his hero and here we go and here he
is
grand mastery karo nakamura with
grandmaster maurice ashley on today's
exciting game
indeed with the tournament leader grand
master hikaru nakamura the us
best player and now i believe the number
four ranked player in the world
after a draw today he should have left
past your
next point you were like 0.7 points
behind so i think you're now number four
in the world uh we can check that
but with the live ratings that should be
the case first of all
you came at the board you know you
surprised us because we all were going
to have
shades on before you came down here but
you
the draw was so quick that we forgot our
plan
okay right he beat us to it what's up
with the with the sun with the ray-bans
uh i don't know i just went to i just
went to st louis galleria earlier and i
bought a pair of sunglasses i didn't you
know
felt like mixing it up considering my
bad score against magnus in the past um
so i mean there's i mean also i mean
from a historic historical standpoint i
think uh
i think it was paul benko who did it
when he played mikhail tower
half a century ago so um i mean
other players have done it i felt like
experimenting trying something new in it
i think it seemed to work
seems to work in your favor absolutely
you also played extremely
bold chess today we saw this move g5
then we saw the move b5
did you feel like you needed to play
super aggressive against him just to
do what well i mean actually i thought i
kind of had to do that because if i
didn't play like that i thought i was
just worse because i mean in the opening
he had magnets had a lot more space
um i mean if i don't try to do something
to get active i'll just end up losing uh
very painfully and very slowly so
i felt like i actually played quite well
um i definitely was better
uh in the game but i'm not really sure
if it was ever enough to win
i mean i thought there was probably one
point when i played some rook a7 where
i maybe could have played the move king
f8 but i still didn't see anything that
was clearly winning and the problem is
there are a lot of different end games
where i'm i'm not
convinced that uh that i can win so
i mean i i tried but you know magnus is
the number one player in the world and
he defended quite well what point in the
game did you feel like it was
stabilizing itself to a draw how early
was that
in your estimation well only at the end
really um i mean because i was still
trying to win up until pretty much the
end but the problem is
is that uh the only idea to try and win
is to play this move e5 and e4
to block the bishop on the h1n8 diagonal
but
the problem is when i do that bishop
comes around the other way to g2 and h3
and then
then the queen's tied down to the rook
um and it's just
there isn't anything i can do in fact i
can end up worse than that that position
if i if i
if i go a little bit crazy now
grandmaster sir one thought that
a good idea was to maybe play for h5 h4
and trade off there and then maybe try
to play for f4 in that position what did
you think about that at the very end you
mean yes
yeah but the problem is white just puts
the king on h3 and waits that's the main
problem mike was keen h3 and bishop g2
and uh i mean i don't see what i'm doing
at all and
once again i think i can end up worse if
i'm not careful so it didn't really
make much sense and you know it was just
much more pragmatic to take a draw at
that point
now you're at two and a half points how
does it feel you're
clearly in first place still i mean it's
it's good i'm playing well so far but
there's still three more rounds and uh
you know in the past i've had some good
good starts tournaments and some rather
epic
collapses so this time around you know
i'm not going to get my hopes too high
i'm just going to try and make good
moves
and on the rest day what do you do you
go hang out
or study well i mean it's really
disappointing that i drew today because
i mean
okay obviously september 11th of course
we all know what happened but at the
same time it's also uh my stepfather's
birthday so
i really really badly wanted to win this
game for him um
but you know it just wasn't enough so i
assume tonight and tomorrow probably go
out and celebrate his birthday a little
bit and then um
also there's a cardinals game which i'm
looking forward to as well even though
i'm not a cardinals fan
uh as everyone knows so what which team
are you a fan of oh of course i'm a
yankees fan
anyone else yes you know i'm from new
york what can i say
you know this is why we like you so much
well we'll see if i'm
so well liked here after today
well thank you so much for joining us
and congratulations on your final result
so far thank you
grand master hikaru nakamura number one
player in the u.s
and look nakamura we see the
our hosts are definitely honoring your
shades today a good luck
a good look a lot of fun just change the
trend up a little bit okay
sure mix it up as he said
well a great game a great round of chess
we've been really really privileged here
for three rounds in a row
uh all the games have been great fights
and
i tell you today i was on the edge of my
seat i think the critical moment
in the game was when hikaru played the
move knight f6 to e4 instead of rook d8
i think magnus might have been under
more pressure
in that case but let's get to
the world's number one player we have
magnus carlsen with maurice ashley
yes indeed jen thank you with the world
number one
magnus carlson after a difficult fight
with hikaru nakamura
magnus first of all were you surprised
at all by the
ray-bans that your opponent came to the
board with have you ever played anybody
else who had shades on
no not really um i don't know why
why he did that uh but okay that's cool
you didn't seem nonplussed in any way
buy it
the game itself though was difficult i
mean he played
hyper aggressively moves like g5 and b5
were you surprised by this and did you
think you handled it well
um yes and no
no no i'm never really surprised when he
plays aggressively that's
that's his style and um i thought g5 was
not really an aggressive move it's just
the logical follow-up to
to his previous ones and uh then we get
this position more or less by force
b5 i was a little bit surprised by
i i thought at first it was too risky
but probably it was was a strong option
and then
then we get one of these positions where
uh there are so many opportunities but
it's very hard to tell
whether any of them are any good and
i felt that i clearly didn't find
find the best line and and i definitely
suffered
did you feel you were in danger of
losing at some point in this game
yeah at some point my position was
getting a bit worse and
i was burning a lot of time as well
but still there was some kind of
inherent solidity to my position when i
given up
the exchange i mean i don't really have
any
weaknesses around my king and
his c pawn is king is always going to be
weak so i didn't feel any particular
danger there
although i i think he could have set me
some some more problems than he did
were you surprised at the draw at the
very end that he stopped so quickly or
did you think he might have tortured you
a little bit more
no i i thought at the end uh you
i guess he realized if he tries to push
e5 and so on
i go e4 myself and and we
he's probably risking as much as i am so
i i
sort of expected him to to give up right
there
that was your second white in the
tournament and
now you're gonna have two blacks and one
white what do you feel about the
remaining games
um well now i'm playing the americans
into next round so
that's going to be interesting uh
especially to see if if kata is going to
play a little more aggressively with
white
than it did today um
and then obviously the game with hikaru
in the fifth round is going to be a big
one and you're
not projecting i guess i i don't even
like to ask this question anymore
because
the answer is always i'll take one game
at a time but what are your projections
for those games
um yeah it was very nice to
to get a win in the first round a little
bit disappointed that i couldn't
make anything of my advantage yesterday
and i had to suffer
today so obviously it doesn't look as
great as it did
after the first round but i think i
think i have
still have um good chances and if i can
score
plus one again again in the last three
rounds i think
uh it's going to be a pretty good result
will be enough to win the tournament the
way nakamura is playing
well if i beat him
indeed well thanks very much for joining
us and good luck in the rest of your
games thank you
world number one magnus carlson after a
tough draw but he held it together going
into the rest day
back to you jen and yaz thank you magnus
is making such great interviews with us
i enjoy his
uh reputation yeah picking up a few
extra fans before he uh heads off to his
world championship match
i think he's making fans of all of us uh
very well spoken and uh
very objective too he recognized so it's
not just his looks you're saying
yeah he's not just a pretty face not
just another pretty face he recognizes
things have gone wrong in these last two
games he's given up
an advantage against aronian where he
really felt and deservedly so that he
should have pressed
and today he was really thrown on the
defensive rather early
and uh he had to scramble to save it
right so
but that being said you know still three
rounds left
and everything to play for everybody
yeah lots of excitement in store and you
you mentioned he pinpointed that uh
fifth round game
against nakamura and now with the black
pieces is going to be a
crucial one for the tournament everyone
make sure you're not doing anything on
saturday
yeah we're all looking for that is the
big day here at the singhfield cup for
us and we're actually getting got a
kamsky set up
and yeah yeah we should uh we should um
mention also the so world championship
in chennai
um coming up in november coming up in
november and not like we were talking
about how
how carlson has so many fans and uh i
heard that even in india some of the
some little kids are rooting for magnets
well i'm sure that's true
that uh that he has fans in india too
but don't forget that
in india really um anand is
really a big sports figure a real
hero right in the same league as cricket
players for the united states that would
be more like
baseball or basketball like right up
there with the major stars of the world
and uh we actually have got a grand
master gotta kamsky our reigning us
chess champion and they're getting set
up
for an interview right now and uh
yeah we're we're going to move to god
and maurice
with the reigning u.s champion
godokomsky after an interesting draw
with grand master aronian welcome gotta
you were mentioning off-camera that you
felt that in this position
you were doing very well throughout the
game and at some point you let it slip
no not really i was playing the opening
just to make a draw and
um and then he gave me some chances with
the king
7 king j8 the move so i got really
excited and then
i couldn't find a plan as i always
screwed up and black was actually better
like after 20 moves or so now you just
said you were playing the opening just
to make a draw that's pretty surprising
considering you're
welcome because the last two games i
realized i'm not really in a good form
so i just needed to recover and to make
a draw and
you know save my energy for the other
games and but
at some point during this game i lost
track of it and black became actually
much better
and but then he let me sleep and the end
game was drawn
it was pretty exciting i guess so
now that you've completed this game you
at least you got your draw that you
wanted what do you think about going
into the next game against
carlson well i'm not thinking about that
game yet i just need to recover
and uh the way i play here i'm not in a
good form so
um we'll see just what do you want me to
say i mean like
well obviously i tried to play every
game like uh it's not like i went and
i decided like okay let's make a draw i
just decided you know play solid chess
and not to take any risks today because
in the first two games against magnus
i just decided to play open chess and
fighting chess and i took risk and i
lost
and yesterday the same thing you know i
just decided to play active chess
sacrifice the pawn for initiative and
then i lost so i decided today just you
know
no more active chess just solid chess
you know professional
draw go home like
indeed well we thank you for
that frankness and good luck in the rest
of your games okay thanks
u.s champion godikomski after
a necessary draw at least to stop the
bleeding back to you jennings
well that has always been the
professional approach that after a loss
or a second loss most especially
you just need to recover your
equilibrium and
playing a solid draw is very very
understandable
on the other hand as god has said he
wasn't very pretentious in the opening
he wasn't fighting for any major
kind of an advantage and then suddenly
he did have something very good
i mean he really had the superior
position
and somehow this conflict between
playing solid and playing all out got
mixed up
and as he said he ended up becoming
worse at a certain moment which was a
big surprise
i think for both players that's right
yeah the game did have a lot of twists
and turns and actually some people are
making fun of us on our hashtag sync cup
because
i can't predict it i know they made fun
of us really i'm shocked
what do they have to jump on there there
you go but anyway they were saying that
we were predicting
a long night of chass and two games that
went down to the absolute wire and two
minutes later
both games were agreed wrong so
apparently we are wrong sometimes you
know
go figure right thank you and uh we do
have our uh
our fourth competitor here that we're
getting set up um and that is uh our
lovely
color-coded lavon oroni ante you're pink
i'm gray and
he's the mixture of both of us yeah
that's right and uh
he is he's with a grandmaster maurice
ashley
and to talk about his game today
indeed with armenian giant
levon aronian the number two player in
the world
had a somewhat shaky start losing the
first game then had a difficult game
drawing that game and now this third
game where
you felt you had some real chances to
maybe even win the game
yeah i won't say i deserve them
because i didn't really play well the
the starting phase
of the game okay i had a really nice
position on the move number 15
and then uh i kind of uh
plundered a little subtle idea
actually at this moment c4
what he played i was planning to take
dtxc and i realized he can play queen c3
here
and then then it's still equal
so but i wasn't happy with this
did you go into the game trying to win
with the black pieces trying to get back
in the tournament
uh it's the chance you know you you have
to try and create chances yourself
and i know that gata is a is a great
player he always fights and he always
tries to
win himself so surprisingly he said that
a draw for him would have been okay
because after his last two
losses he feel he felt like he was
playing badly when he was playing
actively so he wanted to be solid and
maybe even just make a draw so he can
recover
yeah i i had this feel but uh
i kind of tried to you know push for it
try to
you know make him play for a win a
little bit you know
so uh and i almost succeeded
because he had a slight advantage to the
point
uh but then i think i overtook
you know after i played f5 i think i
have an advantage there but then i
didn't have so much time i couldn't
figure out what to play
actually on move number 34 i think queen
f6 was strong
but one thing uh that i didn't like was
king g2
knight e4 taiki rookie four rook c4 show
that one yeah
and so you're saying here you should
have played queen of six
yeah g7 but you didn't wait sorry
somebody told me later
kg2 you didn't like because of knight e4
yeah i didn't like because i saw rook c4
and then
i kind of felt it's some kind of a trap
but here i can practically make any move
for example bishop h5 yeah because his
knight is frozen pinned and you have all
this triangulation attack on his
position
yeah this was definitely my chance and
later on uh
got the plate precisely and position was
equal
so how are you feeling i mean it's like
you're kind of trying to get out of your
own way a little bit
yeah i am i'm trying to recover
after pretty lousy start
but all right at least we had a game i
think i would be unhappier if i just
played
correctly and played for a draw so
next game you get hikaru nakamura again
are you thinking what are you thinking
about that matchup i'll
you know i'll try to
do my best you know i i like to play
against him
he's an interesting opponent and let's
see what happens what did you think
about his ray bans today that was the
talk of
the the tournament him walking in with
those shades on
i he he played in a cap i think before
so i don't know what comes next
indivo thanks so much for joining us and
good luck with the rest of your games
grandmaster levonoronian after a
difficult start we look forward to
seeing his next three games
back to you guys posing the question
what comes next that is a very good
question we do have an
entire day off for nakamura to go
shopping so
maybe it goes for a different hairstyle
different look
well in the driver's seat for that 70k
you know you can do a lot of damage
absolutely absolutely sure you could
come to the board as a blonde what do
you think of that
and nigel short once did it he had his
hair colored
oh i remember that yeah that was pretty
stylish yeah you got to get
like i mentioned earlier the world chess
hall of fame having this massive
chess and fashion show in the fall right
the alexander mcqueen show the biggest
alexander mcqueen show
since uh the absolutely uh blockbuster
one in new york that sold out
every day so it's gonna be a pretty
thrilling
um stuff happening over at the museum as
well and uh
we actually have one more thought from
grandmaster maurice ashley
well i'm thinking he could come in maybe
a liberace jacket
you know certainly a yankee calf would
do him well although i know all the
saint louis fans here
hate me for saying that but nakamura off
to a fantastic start two and a half
out of three you can't ask for anything
more okay you could have asked for three
obviously
but two and a half out of three leading
the pack half a point behind is magnus
carlson
he's got to be disappointed that he
couldn't press nakamura
today and he's going to have black
against nakamura in two days and he has
two blacks left
to go in the tournament so a little bit
of a challenge for him but certainly not
something
he can't overcome the other two tail
enders both of them look like they'd be
happy to play
these three rounds tomorrow and get it
over with because
they don't seem like they have a lot of
energy so they'll need a rest day
so that they can get their brains clear
to be able to fight
for the title of the sink field cup and
i think it's going to be a thrilling
finish
oh yes we can't wait to see what's going
to happen and i think in addition to to
rest and shopping players are
going to see the cardinals game tomorrow
so just a fun packed week here in st
louis if you're not with us already
please join us and to recap we are not
having a game tomorrow
so rest up study your nakamura and
carlson games
and look forward to friday um for round
four where we have gotta kansky playing
with the white pieces against magnus
carlson
i can bet you one thing carlson is not
going to play solid for a draw that game
is going to have some fireworks
without questions and he's hoping that
kanski doesn't play too solid
he says i'm hoping kentucky gives me a
little bit more to chew on than
you might have today right and then
aronian is
going to be playing against nakamura
with white an opponent he's done pretty
well against then
sure to be a very interesting game with
these two creative players
so thanks everyone for all of your
comments on the broadcast
and join us again friday and saturday
and sunday clear your schedules
for the thrilling finale here of the
sinkfield cup
i'm jennifer shahady and i'm signing off
for yasser sarawan maurice ashley and
the whole crew here at the st louis
chess pub thank you
you